- [Sal] In other videos,
we touched on the notion
of kinetic molecular theory,
which I'll just shorten as KMT.
And it's just this idea that
if you imagine a container,
I'll just draw it in 2-dimensions here,
that it contains some gas,
you can imagine the gas
as being these particles
where their collective volume
is much smaller than the
volume of the container.
And the temperature we're dealing with
is related to the average
kinetic energy of the particles.
These particles are all
moving around, zooming around,
and they each would have
some kinetic energy.
Remember, kinetic energy,
you calculate that
as MV squared over two.
So, each of these particles
would have some mass
and some velocity,
but they could all have
different velocities for sure,
even if they're the same type of particle.
And if they're different
types of particles,
they can have different masses as well.
But, the average of these kinetic energies
across all of these particles,
that is proportional to temperature
when measured in Kelvin.
And pressure, the pressure, remember,
pressure is nothing but
force per unit area.
And so, you can imagine this
surface of our container,
this could be some type of a cube
so I can draw it in 3-dimensions here,
so there's some area over here.
And you have your particles,
let me do this in a different color,
these particles are
constantly bouncing off of it
and there's way more particles
then what I have drawn here,
so at any given moment,
you're having some particles
that are bouncing off of
this side of the container,
actually all sides of the container.
And these are perfectly
elastic collisions,
they're preserving kinetic energy.
And so, they're applying
some force, collectively,
on this area, so the pressure is because
of these particle
collisions on the surface.
Now, what I wanna do in this
video is take these ideas
that we conceptualize in
kinetic molecular theory
and to understand why the ideal
gas law, PV is equal to nRT,
make sense when we
conceptualize the world here.
Just a reminder, P is
pressure, V is volume,
n is the number of moles of
whatever gas we're dealing with,
the amount of that gas,
and then T is the temperature in Kelvin,
and R is just the ideal gas constant,
that's just whatever
constant you're doing,
so that the units all work out together.
So, let's first think about
how pressure relates to volume
if we were to old
everything else constant.
Well, the idea gas law tells
us that pressure times volume
is going to be equal to this,
if we hold it at constant,
I can even just write
a K here for constant,
but that would also mean we could divide,
let's say both sides by V,
we can say that pressure is
equal to some constant over V.
Another way to think about
it is is that pressure
is proportional to the inverse of volume.
You could also write this,
if we divide both sides by P,
is that volume is proportional
to the inverse of pressure.
Does that make sense
from a kinetic molecular
theory point of view?
Pause this video and think about it.
Well, imagine we have our
original cube right over here.
And I had the same number of particles,
they have the same average kinetic energy,
but let's say I were
to increase the volume.
So, if I were to make the volume go up,
so I were to some how expand this,
or maybe put the exact number,
the same particles with
the same temperature,
in a larger container,
then at any given moment,
you're just gonna have
fewer bounces of particles
off of the container.
Because they just have more
room to go in that volume,
and even the surface area of the container
is going to be high as well.
So, it makes sense that
if the volume goes up,
the pressure is going to go down.
And you can think about it the other way.
If you make this smaller,
that same number of particles
with the same average kinetic energy,
they're just gonna bump into the container
that much more often.
And that's going to increase the pressure,
so volume goes down, pressure goes up.
And this relationship, that pressure
is inversely proportional
to volume, or vice versa,
if you hold everything else constant,
that's often known as Boyle's law.
Now, another relationship,
what if we were to hold volume
and the number of moles constant,
and we wanna think about the relationship
between pressure and temperature.
Well, this is constant, this
constant, and this is constant,
the ideal gas law would say that pressure
is going to be proportional to temperature
or that temperature's
proportional to pressure.
Does that make sense?
Well, let's go back to
our original container.
If you were to increase the temperature,
that means that the average
kinetic energy is increased.
That means that these particles,
when they hit the side of the container,
they're going to hit
it with more velocity.
That means that you're going
to have, at any given moment,
you're gonna have more pressure
exerted on the side of the container.
And you could go the other way.
Think about lowering the temperature,
so the kinetic energy goes really low,
then these particles are
just slowly drifting.
And the speed with which they are hitting
the side of the container
is going to go down
and so the pressure would go down.
So, it completely makes sense,
if temperature goes up, pressure goes up,
if temperature goes
down, pressure goes down,
and this is often known
as Gay-Lussac's law.
Now, another relationship, and
I'm really just going through
all of the combinations over here,
what if we were to hold pressure
and the number of molecules constant?
So, we're really looking
at the relationship
between volume and temperature.
So, once again, if P, n,
and R is always constant,
if those are constant, the
ideal gas law would tell us
that the volume is proportional
to the temperature,
once again, holding
everything else constant.
Well, to think about
that you can go through
that same thought experiment we just had.
If we increase the temperature,
if these things are moving around faster,
if you want to have the
same amount of force
per area on the container,
on the side of the container,
you're going to have
to increase the volume.
So, this relationship, which
is completely consistent
with kinetic molecular theory,
is often known as Charles's law.
Now, another one is the
relationship between volume
and the number of moles.
If everything else is held constant,
the ideal gas law would
tell us that volume
is going to be proportional
to the number of moles
of our particle, or of our
gas that we are dealing with.
And that makes sense 'cause, once again,
you're holding everything else constant,
you want pressure to be constant,
temperature to be constant.
If I were to double the
number of particles here,
but I don't wanna change the
pressure or the temperature,
makes sense that I would
have to double the volume.
Likewise, if I wanted to
double the volume here
and I didn't wanna change the
pressure or the temperature,
I would have to put twice
as many particles in there,
so I still have sufficient
number of interactions
of bouncing of the particles
with the sides of the container,
so that I have sufficient pressure.
And this notion is called Avogadro's law.
Last but not least,
let's say I have two identical containers.
I have two identical containers,
that's one there, that's one over here,
actually I'm gonna draw that
same container a third time.
And let's say over here, I have gas one
and in this case, it has
some pressure due to gas one,
we're gonna assume the
volume and the temperatures
are the same across all three of these.
And let's say we have gas two
and it is exerting pressure too,
if I were to take all of
the gas in both of them,
and put them both into
this third container,
so this third container is
gonna have all of the original
of gas one and all of
the original of gas two,
but we aren't changing the volume
and we aren't changing the temperature.
In any given unit area on
the surface of the container,
you're gonna get the
collisions from particle one,
which would give you P1 in
that force per unit area
and you're going to get the
collisions from particle two,
which would give you
that force per unit area.
So, it makes sense that the
partial pressures would add up
to be equal to the total
pressure in the container.
And this is known as Dalton's law.
But, the whole point of this
video is just appreciate
that everything we've talked about
with the ideal gas law,
actually makes a lot of sense,
I would argue it makes the most sense,
when you think about it
in terms of kinetic molecular theory.